left handedness whether you are
left-handed or right-handed we have some
research here today on Bloomberg
surveillance data Tom you know what's
you know what you know what the fancy
latin word is for left-handedness Finian
etre yeah oh man you must have an
advanced degree all right so there's a
research from joshua goodman at harvard
in the journal of economic perspectives
which i know you read eagerly cover
cover as it arrives every great man is
ever parsley and he looked at the
long-term consequences of
left-handedness now we have this her
istic that we use where we assume that
because president obama has left-handed
Bill Gates is left-handed they feel
over-represented in high-power positions
but actually if you look across all
left-handers they're more likely to do
poorly on tests and they're going to
they're likely to earn ten to twelve
percent lower over their lifetimes
they're also more likely to die at a
younger age really why more accident
prone it's a right-handed world from
doorknobs to you know kitchen appliances
everything is geared towards
right-handers you know Bill Gates is
left-handed president obama's
left-handed Oprah Winfrey is left-handed
they're doing okay for themselves but
that's interesting that the rate of
accidents go up we haven't figured out a
way around it I mean they have those red
left-handed scissors and Ned Flanders on
The Simpsons open the left Tory that's
about it is there are the else catering
to these South paws so my sons are at
that age where we're eagerly watching to
see whether they're left-handers or
right-handers to see whether they'll
have an unnatural advantage of some kind
of sport of their choice but we don't
know yet right now they're just
basically incompetent